all right Avengers endgame it is out
officially if you haven't seen it yet
don't watch this video this is my
avengers endgame spoiler talk that's a
spoiler warning right there I just
wanted to be spoiled for if you would
any comment section in the past two days
it's already spoiled might as well stick
around but if you didn't if it's not
spoiled probably want to bounce if
you've already seen the movie or you
don't care hey welcome let's talk some
Avengers in-game spoilers because I feel
like this video is gonna be longer than
normal I don't know how long it's going
to be I haven't even started talking
about it another feeling so spoiler
warning ready can I talk about the movie
in three two one
stealing that wasn't meant for you that
wasn't meant for anybody I just did it
cuz so the fingers endgame so the
trailer pitched the first act of the
movie rest of the movie no idea
don't know where it's going like by
comparison imagine a trailer for Return
of the Jedi
only all it shows is the Jabba's palace
stuff like imagine the entire movie
looks like they're saving han Solo I was
like oh no Emperor and Vader and
confrontation and Endora I guess was
like a whole movie there that wasn't
even shown in the trailer it beat
something like that well actually the
movie starts out you see Hawkeye with
his families teaches daughter how to
shoot a bow and arrow they're at a
picnic and you know you know it's coming
but how else was this gonna go you're
just waiting it's like you're watching a
car wreck in slow-mo just oh he turns
around his daughters gone doesn't know
where she went
turns around his entire family's gone
doesn't know where they went and yeah it
happened I will say when the Marvel logo
comes up
song plays music plays some dear mr.
Fanning's ago a great song I just think
it came out a little too soon there
wasn't enough time to go
they let the drama of it marinate for a
minute and then had the music come on I
think that would have been a little
better neither here nor there point is
movie goes on Tony Stark's in a
spaceship with nebula they're just
they're hanging out they've run out of
gas cuz I guess spaceships stopped in
space when they run out of gas is that
like a Disney thing why do spaceships
stop in space when there's no resistance
no friction when they run out of gas and
we just keep going remember they are
going they could be going but it's in
the dead of space you're not gonna
notice it moving at all there's nothing
around to reference that you are moving
it on whatever pointers Captain Marvel
comes out of nowhere and then gets Tony
Stark and then brings them back to earth
actually they're really good job at
making Tony Stark look sickly and thin
like he hasn't
a lot in the past three weeks I was
really well done and he's just really
pissed and he collapses this is just the
setup because they find out where Thanos
is because I guess he used the stones
again they all go there it's like let's
get this son of a [ __ ] but but but
that's right let's get this son of a
[ __ ] line was before the titles even
came on in this movie this is all just
set up they find him on this farm he
used the stones to destroy the stones
the stones are just gone now Thor goes
for the head sack so just cuts his head
off like all right I guess Thanos is
dead all that builds up how they're
gonna fight the head hoes get revenge
all just in the setup of the movie he
gets decapitated then there's a time
jump five years later it's just five
years later earth we've all just kind of
moved on well we're trying to move on
not everyone's it's not easy to move on
there's a whole monument of people who
disappeared but right at that point it
was like what's the plot of this movie I
thought the plot was to get Daniel soon
now he's dead what's this movie about
time travel that's right so when ant-man
comes back after a rat randomly steps on
a button and just saves existence I
guess two Ninja Turtles crossover
friends that's a sentient rat his name
is splinter but you have so ant-man's
like wait a minute times different in
the quantum realm so if we can harness
it and control it we might be able to
come out in different times and get the
stones and use the stones to bring
people back take Thanos down they try to
confront Tony Stark who's married to
Pepper Potts has a daughter now and he's
like no peace I'm out of the fight oh
he's working on the time-travel thing
he's trying to get it going so was he
working on it after they came to him or
had he been working on it all along I
don't really know but if he'd been
working on it all along Scott Lang gave
them no new information so the rats not
that important but now there's five
years later everyone's in different
places like Hawkeye is just murdering
bad guys Hawkeye is awesome in this
movie dude this dude is just straight-up
he's ninja he's grown in style Bruce
banners the Hulk but not really the Hulk
it's like he's reconciled with the Hulk
and now he's big and green but he's
Bruce banners mine's a Hulk smart no
taking selfies with kids who don't
recognize ant-man it's okay no one
really does you know haka you know
renters like thank god ant-man happened
those used to be jokes aim to make my
other times have changed Thor is a fat
slob but that cracks me up but if you're
like a super Thor fan this is probably
gonna piss you off already seen a few
people like what the [ __ ] they do to my
favorite character there's new Asgard
all the survivors of as
which a population of the ship as I
understand it danos killed half of them
then the other half were killed after
the snap so really it's a quarter of
Asgardians here in this little shitty
Harbor town and Thor just drinks a lot
of Baird and he's it he's he has more
mass mass of the gods but he feels guilt
to him he's like I threw the axe at
Thanos and it didn't hit his head and
he's snap people have my fault I should
aim for his head or was kind of a
hedonist before he learned his lesson in
the original Thor because of that guilt
he's just gonna revert back to what he
was doing before now he doesn't have
that metabolism I guess he just can't
take the beer carbs like he used to I
will say the marketing department in
these Marvel movies just crazy like when
they're all like marching and they're
ant-man suits and they're gonna go
through time for when he's walking is
puffy Thor with a big long beard and
long hairs no not in the trailer not on
the poster like that scene from the
posters in the intro of the movie that's
not even Thor from this movie I'll give
him that they do a good job at keeping
secrets
so the main plot that you never saw in
the trailer was they have to go to
different timelines and get the stones
from those timelines bring them back and
then snap Thanos well snap Thanos in his
armory anyway out of existence so they
go to different movies from the MCU they
go to the beginning of guardians of the
galaxy vol 1 they go to throw the dark
world the big Throwdown in New York the
Avengers so here they actually poke fun
at the fact that like wait a minute if
we go to the right moment there are
three stones in New York three Infinity
stones of existence in this one city of
this one world what are the odds of that
but the fact that they're going to these
moments that we've already seen but it's
like a different angle of that moment it
reminded me the movie I compared it to
well I didn't compare to the movie I
said it reminded me of a movie the movie
is back to the future - it totally
reminded me of Back to the Future 2
we're back to the future - they're
trying to get the Almanac back from Biff
and so they go back to the events of
Back to the Future 1 but there are other
soldiers there they're trying to avoid
their other selves it totally reminded
me of that but this movies very
self-aware it it absolutely positively
embraces that fact like the great
philosopher Tyrion Lannister once said
never forget what you are the rest of
the world will not wear it like armor it
can never be used to hurt you there
would still be some [ __ ] talk whether or
not it hurts it I don't know emcees not
necessarily sentience I don't think fog
'is gonna cry and his [ __ ] money
shaped pillow but this movie does wear
it like armor it's like all this plots
familiar - back to the future - we'll
actually have
got Lange reference back to the future
in this movie this movie is fanservice
you know will blatantly have the plot be
fanservice we're gonna take fans on a
joyride through some of the previous
stories of the MCU a full tour has
become full circle and close this book I
did like that Tilda Swinton was in it
because I like I am but that place is in
New York and logically it's like does
that mean they were there in the events
of the first Avengers so you do see here
like doing her spells and wiping out
monsters so you know it was happening
before we just didn't see it because I
did she wasn't the stars isn't it a
little tie in I like the fact that they
tied that in but she even says like no
you got to put these stones back after
you take them because if the stones are
removed from reality you're gonna [ __ ]
our reality because by doing that you're
creating a variance so you're creating
an alternate timeline so it's not
necessarily gonna affect you this is
generally this is the accepted way time
works and time-travel now it used to be
like a Marty McFly is gonna disappear
now it's like no if you change the past
Marty won't disappear Marty's timeline
will be the same it'll still exist but
now this is creating another timeline
this movie kind of breaks it down which
I appreciate I'm glad the movie that had
a spaceship stopped in the dead of space
because it ran out of gas could show
that they wanted to have attention to
detail and a came to time-travel yeah
it's just like now you got to put the
stones back so you know they're gonna
have to do that after all this wraps up
which funny enough animals destroyed the
stones with the stones so now
essentially those stones don't exist in
that universe like the main MCU universe
so is it gonna [ __ ] everything up I
don't know I do not know I think they
just might have overlooked that matter
that's gonna be the entirety of face
football those [ __ ] stones just gonna
be in every face but there were some
great throwback moments when they were
in these other timelines like Robert
Redford because it was mr. secretary and
all that in Captain America Winter
Soldier which means he would be in the
events of the Avengers I'm actually
baffle of how many people they got to
come back to reprise their roles even
for a small time Captain America even
gets in the elevator with crossbones all
these guys
he was looking around I thought he was
gonna be like before we get started does
anyone want to get out but no he just
goes guys it's okay the secretary sent
me that's what a man does when he has
America's Loki escape so he gets the
tesseract making them have to go get the
tesseract from another time in the 70s I
believe but look he grabs a tesseract he
totally these bounces he escapes naked
away
for I guess Loki's having his own TV
show right so I imagine it's gonna be
that there was a Stan Lee cameo back
then was this CGI or was that actually
Stan Lee did they get that filmed before
he passed I don't actually know I guess
that shows how good they are at that
technology doesn't matter because the
entire crowd cheered people dude come on
I cheered that's amazing you have to do
this the end game but I just like seeing
Stan Lee I also like that Tony Stark got
a moment with Howard Stark like he does
all that should have going but I'm glad
like you know because Tony Stark's
always had a vision of his dad and now
he gets to talk with him while he's kind
of in line with his dad they're about
the same age they both have a kid you
got to connect with him he saw how it
was gives him a hug was really awkward
for Howard was glad he got that I'm glad
it happened which is funny because they
were like oh we're out of Pym particles
and this is all we have knows like
you're time-traveling why not get Pym
particles when it just go to the past
and get them oh they do all right
good on you movie actually likes nebula
to nebulas been one of those characters
from like all right you're kind of
overcooking it in the guardians of the
galaxy movies I didn't actually connect
with her too much but in this movie I
really liked her and it does show how
far they've come the daughters of Thanos
nebula Gamora because they go back it's
like oh no we're villains and we're
looking for the stones
we're actually baddies right now and you
see that nebula so wants the approval of
Thanos and she's just not getting it so
she dicks out and replaces other nebula
because - nebula lives in one timeline
is just like freaks her out because the
Bluetooth connection shorted out her
internet started showing images I
actually thought phantoms was gonna see
Tony Stark and that's how he would have
known who Stark was in Avengers infinity
war when he was like stark you're not
the only one burdened with knowledge I
thought that was how he was gonna learn
who Tony Stark was in the past but
wouldn't make sense cuz he's got to go
down in this movie I actually thought
nebula might have actually gotten the
Infinity Gauntlet at one point because
she does in the graphic novel actually
read Infinity Gauntlet last weekend it
was really good this movie goes in a
completely different direction I'm
baffled they didn't bring Adam warlock
in like why would you tease Adam warlock
at the end of guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 and then not bring an Adam
warlock for this that's weird but they
didn't after reading the book I told I
was like this is gonna be the greatest
kept secret in modern cinema Adam
warlock is gonna come strolling through
he's gonna be some big actor we didn't
know was going to be Adam Worrell
did not happen and nebula did not get
the Infinity Gauntlet at any point but
whatever they got to go to the planet
Boromir or whatever and get the soul
stone look I know it's called for me I
just I think of Boromir every time I
hear Vermeer that's what I think that's
Black Widow and Hawkeye and of course
you have to lose something you love so
they're all like huh
I'll get this movie this I totally
thought I'm like Oh Hawkeye is gonna go
because he lost his family and he's
really damaged he's been killing people
out there that he doesn't want to be
like that he's got sins he feels he
needs to atone for so he's going over
the edge and those two go at it it's
just like one runs from it she shocks
him then he shoots an arrow when she's
running forward and blasts her to the
side and I was like all right he's going
and he doesn't go I mean they both
really care about each other so it makes
sense that those two are the ones there
but yeah he goes over the edge she goes
over the edge and he has a hold of her
and he just can't pull them both up and
she's like it's all good let me go and
so that's the end of Black Widow she
dies yep she's gone she's not gonna be
running shield now little confused is
how they're gonna do her standalone
movies it can't be Scarlett Johansson
this is gonna be her when she's younger
different actress I don't know different
timeline I did the thing about the
deaths the endings they need to be they
can't undo them it'll mean too little if
they undo them whatever happened in this
movie man it needs to stick but I was
actually I was really sad and shocked
because again the logical thing would be
Hawkeye going over and was like nah
fooled you but man they really got lucky
and sending the two people who actually
do care about each other what if what if
two people went who don't really care
about each other that much you have to
lose what you love most right they love
most that's the phrase what if they were
like all right we don't know where we're
gonna run into there so we need
something big something small Bruce
Banner Scott Lang you're both going
there alright cool let me get there like
I gotta lose what I love most I mean
you're alright now I don't think this is
gonna work like what if it was two
people who don't care about each other
that much I mean really if you really
think about it in this movie in
particular you could've just sent Thor
there with a keg coulda walked out of
this with one more Avenger so just be
this throw is keg over like a huh I got
the stomach no that's cool anyhow this
movie it has conveniences but the I'll
get into them a little more the ones
that people like Gould makes no sense
but the MCU is full of them this entire
universe
is full of [ __ ] doesn't make sense
just convenient I mean I'm kind of like
a mid doesn't make a lot of sense here
or in the reviews but it's not like I'm
like nope Stonewall movies not good now
so yeah point it's black widow die and
when they get back to HQ Santos is like
yeah I know where they are
and he just bombs the plays I thought
they'd die I thought a few of them died
that ant-man was definitely dead which
leads to the best superhero throwdown
ever in a movie ever actually I think
first of [ __ ] the ho okay we got mmm
rewind with me so they have all the
stones now they're at headquarters like
alright so they put it on an Iron Man
glove on stark Tech the only ones strong
enough to live through it is actually
Bruce Banner so he puts it on like fries
half of his body and Starks like bring
everyone back change nothing else don't
let my daughter disappear so he does he
snaps and then fan was just firebombs
the [ __ ] out of that place so yeah he
wants that gauntlet is like sweet I got
the garlic for me I know I succeed
because I've seen [ __ ] in nebulas memory
where I'm like I know I succeed life is
good I am inevitable and after Thanos
bombs at the leaps to the greatest
superhero Throwdown in superhero movie
history I guess makes the airport scene
in civil war look like a mild argument
however are speaking of conveniences so
stark tech can just hold the power of
the stones now I mean if you really
think about that Thanos had to go to
this place that's surrounding the heart
of a dying star or a bunch of giants can
forge a device that can handle the
stones it's so important this is the
place the place mule near was forged
this is the only place that can do it I
guess or he could have just gotten some
stark tax or he could have just built a
glove he looks like he has better
technology than Earth has so if Tony
Stark can do it Thanos can just make it
you know the mom make it or something
the greatest device ever the only device
that can harness the power of the stones
in oven mitts but also the Infinity
Gauntlet or if you know Iron Man glove
same shade I don't know I didn't buy
that I was fine with it by the end
because it led to a great moment and
really in the end it's it's the moment
it's the feeling that resonates with me
that really Trump's all that matters but
man this throwdown this was crazy was
just it was everybody I mean it's
can pretty grim there for a bit it's
like all right you guys you might lose
then you see King T'Challa his sister
and his mom's they come walking in a
friend you're like oh yeah banner
snapped their back they should be back
and everybody everybody comes back
everybody you've ever know to the MCU
that ever had a power kind of was here
it reminded me of the last throw down
and ready player one but with all MCU
characters all MCU characters you've
been attached to for the last decade or
at different points along the line in
the past decade anyway yeah a point Tony
Stark see strange and he's like you told
me there was one where we make it tell
me this is it strange is like if I tell
you what will happen it won't happen
which is really important and I'll talk
about that in a second there's also a
holy [ __ ] moment like a like a holy [ __ ]
moment what come on I got a glimpse of
it age of Ultron when cap was trying to
pick up Milne there and it kind of it
moved a millimeter the Thor's being held
down you see Mele near you like I was
gonna come and Thor's gonna grab it and
kick some ass know what goes BAM right
past him goes right to cap cap boom just
has me linear now I was like holy [ __ ]
that was a holy [ __ ] comic-book movie
moment right there
here's how you give goosebumps hold my
meal NER yeah hold my beer Captain
Marvel even comes in actually Dutchess
trunk she is a head but sir he's just
like bling-bling I was like all right so
you're strong her hair cut it's pretty
fresh I like your new hair but even then
vanish just takes the Power Stone into
his fist is like just sends her in the
next year not actually next year yet
this is a time-traveling movie I can't
use exaggerations like that here he
punches her and she flies really far but
that's it you know there are a lot of
people like is she gonna take down fat
is he's gonna have her come in and take
him out but she doesn't she doesn't do
it like she's conveniently used yes I've
seen the argument they're all like she's
simply a deus ex machina yeah it's like
the MC is full of that [ __ ] like I've
said before full of conveniences that's
just right into the movie to write
themselves out of a thing that they
wrote themselves into everywhere in the
MCU it hasn't mattered before now what
now this is gonna matter yeah she saved
Tony Stark from starving to death in
deep space with nebula is it
unbelievable possibly but what's more
believable after Captain Marvel came to
earth because of Nick Fury's little
beeper and she said where's fury and she
got the lowdown as to what
and rocket was there might have a
tracking device on that ship knew where
the ship was but just couldn't get to
him and sends her to go get him I mean
that's the guardians of the galaxy ship
right like that's Rockets car I imagine
it as GPS on his car since he lacks the
ability to go get it he just the hey can
you go get it there might be friends on
there and should go get or an Iron Man
glove can harness the power of the
stones
what's more convenient what's more
believable right Thor gets his new axe
he needs to get back to earth what does
Pete Dinklage say dosoo summon the
Bifrost oh [ __ ]
I guess it can cuz he needs to get back
so that's how it's written but a great
moment does happen fan OHS has the
gauntlet he goes I am inevitable clunk
and Tony Stark shows that up while he
was tussling with him he got the stones
he has his Iron Man glove and he goes I
am Iron Man and they all disappear
Thanos's army just turns to dust I know
sits down turns to dust Tony Stark is in
really bad shape and the man who started
it all the man of the first movie of the
MCU that we all doubted at least I
doubted the [ __ ] out of him like Iron
Man's gonna suck Iron Man was great Iron
Man started something that hadn't been
done in movies ever Batman Tony Stark
gave His life that day to take down
Stannis he's all burned up and [ __ ] up
I mean Incredible Hulk yeah he can
survive it someone's stronger can
survive it not him he's just a guy it's
actually a really sad moment sad
farewell you see the Iron Man things the
arc reactor on his chest you're like
it's really it really happened he is a
funeral the whole thing black widow
didn't get a funeral but Tony Stark did
Majan she got a funeral it just it
wasn't it wasn't the thing it's not the
person who started the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for us which really makes what
dr. strange told Tony Stark profound
also the fact that Doctor Strange saved
Tony Stark's life because you saw the
one reality in which they live and he's
like alright gotta give him the time
stone him you will use the stones later
and I'm gonna disappear
but in endgame with Tony Stark look too
strange and he was like you saw one
reality where we win tell me this is it
and strange responded if I tell you what
happens it won't happen
Baba because if he says yeah you get the
stones snap kill yourself but you take
him out you'd have enough time to be
like do I want to do that he might
hesitate when it comes down to it when
he's gonna take the stones you'd be like
do i well I want to see my wife and kid
she had to just be in the moment
knowing how it was gonna go down until
he had it and he knew he was gonna snap
there's actually a cool thing it's a
cool knows a good full circle moment
strange you knew what he was doing ever
since infinity war actually why did I
didn't why didn't start getting burned
to death Hulk put that thing on that
glove was burning him because of the
power of all the stones before he even
snapped it dark puts it on like I am
Iron Man
shouldn't he be like clean this weird he
he took that power pretty well better
than the Hulk did until he snapped and
got eight degree burns on all of his
internal organs Captain America is no
longer in this but he doesn't die see
cap has to go back and return the stones
so he goes oh my god I bring him back in
three two one I was like he's not gonna
get brought back but why and of course
he's not getting brought back and you
see this old guy on a bench and it's him
deve Rogers just sitting there he's like
after I returned the stones figured I'll
just have a normal life so he settled
down with Peggy Carter and just lived a
life I loved these endings of these two
characters Tony Stark you know he had
his normal life but like he said he was
Iron Man Captain America is the soldier
but he just wants a normal life so they
both went out they left the MCU the way
they should leave the MCU I thought that
was really touching I just loved the
fact that they didn't have to kill
Captain America Captain America just he
just left the fight leaving it to other
people now Falcon can be Captain America
and there is no post-credit scene not in
this one which is great like if there
was a post-credits scene I would want it
to be like a flower with like a sunrise
in the background or something something
kind of symbolic like oh it's a new day
it's a new dawn it's a new phase of
Marvel but this story is done because
that's what it feels like
post-credit scene would have been just
out of place I love the fact that this
ends dies in the end defenders endgame
it was it was such a fulfilling ending
it lives up to its name not only does it
feel like the end game it feels like the
period at the end of the last sentence
at the end of the last paragraph at the
end of the last chapter at the end of
this book there will be other books
written yes there'll be other chapters
in the MCU other phases but this story
that's been building
for the past 11 years it does come to a
close the one who starred in the movie
that started it all Tony Stark gave his
life to take out the big baddie who's
been building that whole time the leader
Captain America went off and had his
wonderful life Captain America's ending
reminds me of the episode the inner life
from Star Trek The Next Generation Grant
it makes Captain America Winter Soldier
a little creepier because that's his
nation ow like I I'm trying to phrase
this very carefully and I mean this in
the most positive way possible the most
fulfilled way possible like if they were
like there are no more MCU movies this
is it this is the wrap-up and our saga
is now done and there are no more movies
after this I'd be fine with it I'd be
like that's a fine ending that felt
really good I have my 22 movie saga the
likes of which I haven't had a 22 movie
saga like that before
cool so going forward they want to
experiment I'm totally down with it do
anything you want to have the Incredible
Hulk have a [ __ ] dick coming out of
his forehead he just swings it around
like a battering ram takes people I
don't care do it I'll be there I'll
laugh if that happens I'm looking
forward to seeing what they do with the
MCU so now is the time you know now it's
the time or they can try new things
bring in new characters throw things at
the wall see what sticks funny enough
before cap takes the stones back and has
to replace the stones from where they
took them could he use the stones to
bring Tony Stark back like he couldn't
with Black Widow but I feel like that's
because if she was to sacrifice for the
stone but could Tony Stark just be
brought back I don't know it doesn't
really explain I feel like we might be
able to though guess we'll never know
but thank you for watching this as
videos a bit longer than normal this and
the MCU leading up to this was an
experience I never thought I'd see when
I was in junior high we look uh they'll
never make an Avengers movie because
they can never do it and they did it and
they crushed it we're here alright so
now I will ask you Avengers end game
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]